ポンッ
ブーブー
今日はどうキターはるな愛だけで今日の動画ですねちょっとあるものを使ってやって
いきたいと思いますこちら
ないっていうね今回はこちら巨大な段ボールを5つほど準備したんだがこの中に入って
いることが肝心です
あれあれ肝心の何が入ってるか重須見ていきましょう
あーこれからこれこれねこれ俺ねってよ
今回使うのはこちら本当剤ですまあ梱包材とはいわゆる
何か物とかもう配達とか運ぶときにそのなら壊れもだったりバレーものだったりした時
に運ぶ時にこれ可能性があるの猫使ったときの衝撃とか吸収されるために一緒にい
られることがありますそれです
なんかに空気が入って
ですねすごい感情で大事なものは個あると睾丸とかで高校第入れておくとそういう気が
気でもよくを吸収するんで追われなくなると今度はこちらの梱包材よ
つまりちょっと多すぎるので場所変更
数えてみた結果1発行にキャッツクローは梱包材が入っているので合法変わってると a
袋包装ないか今回この場でありますちょっと全部開けていきましょう
まだ合うか
音程います
ねみんな聞いてくれちょっと予想よりたくさんあるな
今防災のいえば安全を守る衝撃を吸収するのでそういう気が出たりと安全なんです私は
そこに感動を覚えたこの梱包材先行私の体に全部巻いて史上最強にもうたぶん世界一番
安全でしょ
世界で一番安全なプロテクトスーツ
を作り103系のボディを手に入れようと思います yeah
ちっこいん
ん
ええええええ
お酢
1件
are you do 完成しましたこれこそが混合剤成功を身にまとった大京の
ポニーすっ
この私にかかればどうぞ強い根拠を言っハッハーコンヌース
ホッ
本気にする
本気に見えるようにしますいやー結構から事故は
ああああ
痛くないいけるぞこれ
ポッポー
big eye ai ああああ
トシこい
はぁ
日だぞ
ポンッ t 2うわあああああああ
パワーどうすればいい re
me
goo
too
th
某それじゃあね
ん
しています